this is an apartment block in beijing
that's had a couple of covert cases and
it's been entirely sealed off we'll take
you a bit closer
and have a look now beijing is basically
under a lockdown right now schools are
shot gyms are shot restaurants are sharp
parks are sharp but they're not calling
it a lockdown they've had a handful of
cases 24 but these are the strict
measures that are taking place if you
look here they've been fencing up the
whole thing and the rest of us are free
to walk around but if you are caught
with a cobra case you're sent to a
centralized quarantine so dr tedros has
come up with this comment
saying it is unsustainable looking at
what's happening in shanghai in
particular where they've had a very
strict lockdown for six weeks now
you can see all these guards outside
this place here making sure no one gets
out they're taking deliveries as well
they have been working really really
hard on this pandemic
um and the question is whether really
you can keep doing that when we have
vaccines and we'll get out there
um
these are called the big whites because
of their big white suits the ppe and
there's lots of them all around beijing
the question is why is china sticking
with this and that reason is it hasn't
vaccinated enough of its elderly
population around 100
million people still haven't had a
vaccine and as a result they're sticking
with this covered zero the problem for
many people is wondering whether they
have a passcode vaccination because of
that covert zero policy they're spending
so much time as you can see
behind me enforcing that policy they're
not vaccinating people enough the rate
of vaccination has been dropping so
that's left a lot of people looking at
us saying well look is this coveted zero
as a means to an end or is this an end
in itself this sort of control is this
new normal for china